[موسيقى]
هنتكلم مع بعض عن المنح من على السفر بره
مين عاوز بره منحه
يعني يكون مصروف عليه كل حاجه اكل وشربه
ايه الناس دي كلها
يعني ايه
يعني ايه محنه منحه
يعني ايه منحه
مساعده ماشي
يعني ايه منحه لا الناس ركز
سافر فري
يعني ايه منحه
ببلاش
فلوس
منحه يعني
هبه
عطيه جايزه 4 فري حاجه مش هندفع فيها اي
حاجه طب انا عاوز اعرف حاجه كلمه منحه
اللي بعديه
كلمه منحه ذات نفسها
هل هي تماما
المنح يا اما بتكون ودي صغيره قوي او
عددها قليل قوي
المتفوقين جدا او بيكون حاجه اسمها
بتلاقي منها تدفع فيها عشره في الميه واحد
في الميه خمسين في الميه تسعين في الميه
تسعه وتسعين في الميه حسب نوع المنحه وحسب
الجهه المانحه في منح كتير جدا تقدمها
الكثير والكثير من الجهات
او الحكومه الامريكيه الحكومه البريطانيه
زي الحكومه التركيه لو عارفين المنح دي
كلها الحكومه اليابانيه الحكومه الكوريه
حتى الحكومه المصريه بتقدم هنا والازهر
بتقدم هنا كمان ودول كتير جدا جدا
فالموضوع متكامل وموجود في بلاد كتيره جدا
جدا معنا نخش اللي بعديه
طب مين اللي يستحق المنحه احنا بقى فلوس
ببلاش مش عارف ايه فلوس احسن كل الكلام ده
مين يستحقها
مين بجد يستحقها
حد بيكون متفوق
ولما نقول كلمه متفوق على طول متفوق ايه
يعني الشخص ده بيكون دحيح الشخص ده بيجيب
اعلى الدرجات صح ولا لا
هو صح
بس مش كل حاجه يعني انت صح ان هو متفوق
اكاديميا او متفوق رياضيا النهارده معنا
زياده بطل العالم سيف
نفس الناس بتحبك يا زياد الله الله
فممكن متفوق اكاديميين زي حد اول على
الدفعه
بتاعته زي كيمياء الناطله وقال او زياد في
منحه يعني عشان هو شخص رياضي او تفوق
اجتماعي حد بيساعد غيره وبيساعد غيره هنا
مش بس بيدي مساعده ماليه ولا حاجه لا هو
متطوع زي الناس الجميله اللي معنا
النهارده دي كلها
في لفظ مصري عتيق يقول لك هيقعد لك عارفين
المثل ده
العيال دي هيقعد لهم في ايه بعد كده لو جه
يقدمه على وظيفه تدريب منحه اللي هم انت
كنت فين وانت صغير انا كنت قاعد بذاكر
بروح النادي انا بابا ماما في الساحل
وغيرك انا كنت بنظم النهارده مش عارف قد
ايه مش عارف المطوع في جمعيه ايه ولا في
مكان ايه بعمل كذا كذا الحاجات دي كلها
فالتطوع هو مهم جدا جدا في مقوله سمعتها
امبارح من حد من هنا من الناس بتقول لي
اذا اردت ان تتطور فاستبدل الراء بالعين
تطوع
تطوع هيديك كل حاجه انت محتاجه عشان تعرف
تسافر تعليم احسن
حاجات كثير جدا مش بس منح الموضوع بره عن
كده الموضوع كمان ايه
نفسيا تلاقي حد متطوع زعلان او متضايق على
طول بيساعد غيره عنده طاقه وبياخد طاقه
كمان حلوه جدا جدا نخش بقى فتفوق اكاديمي
او تفوق رياضي او تفوق اجتماعي اللي بعديه
المطلوب بسرعه ما عندناش احنا قلنا كبسول
ايه المطلوب مش هناخذ من حق او اقدم اصلا
في منحه
بحبه جدا لك يعني ايه
حظ
يعني
لما انت تكون جاهز بورقك بفيزا بجواز سفر
محضر اوراق معينه علشان لو جت اي فرصه
تسافر فتعالوا مع بعض نعرف ايه الخطوات
اللي نعملها من دلوقتي عشان اكون جاهزين
مش لازم تكون عارفين منحه معينه بنؤدي
فيها دلوقتي مش لازم تكون في منحه هتفتح
الشهر الجاي وتحضر لها لا قدم معي من
دلوقتي وحضر نفسك من دلوقتي علشان تكون
جاهز لاي فرصه تجيلك فبتكون محظوظ ساعتها
مش بس مجرد ان حد وقع عليا نصيب او خد او
ورث فلوس او يتقال له خد فلوس اهي وخلاص
لا الموضوع بيجي من
اول حاجه احنا محتاجينها هي
الابلكيشن محتاجين خمس حاجات بالضبط اول
حاجه هنا
في المنح سهله جدا وبسيطه بس طويله
احنا محتاجين نخش على اربع خمس ست سبع 15
منحه نشوف الابلكيشن بتميل ازاي وهتلاقي
حاجات بيرسل اسمك وسنك وايميلك وتاريخ
ميلادك وكل الحاجات دي وحبت اسئله تانيه
هتلاقيها مكتوب مقالات صغيره تاني حاجه
هيت معناها بيان الدرجات انت لسه طالب في
ثانوي فيقول لك انا عاوز اعرف انت عملت
ايه في الاعدادي او في ثانيه وفي ثالثه لو
انت في ثالثه مثلا ثانوي لو انت في اول
اولى جامعه هحتاج منك بين الدرجات ويكون
مترجم بالانجليزي لقبل كده وحاوز اعرف
خلفيتك الاكاديميه كانت عامله ازاي بتقول
انا هستحق المنحه واستحقت عليهم احسن
واستحق فرصه احسن في الحياه هو فين طيب
خلفيتك الاكاديميه اللي بتقول ان انت شخص
مجتهد على الاقل مش هقول لك انت جايب 100%
في كل حاجه بس على الاقل عاوز اعرف انت
كنت عامل ازاي في قلب الدراسه بتاعتك
فتكون جاهز بها يكون معك بيان درجات لو
انت في تانيه كليه هات اللي حصل في اولى
وانت خلاص تتجامعه هات بكل الحاجات دي
كلها بعديها عملت ماجستير هات كلب ما
عملتش حاجه خالص هات اي سنه اكاديميه انت
عشتها فاول حاجه ابليكيشن الحاجه تالت
حاجه هي
ما اجمل انه يطلب منك وتكون جاهز واحد
اصلا
معناها خطاب تزكيه او توصيه ببساطه خالص
ده راي حد فيك ويكون اتنين بيحتاج منك
اتنين واحد بيكون حاجه اكاديميه برضو عاوز
تشوف برضو تحصيلك الدراسي عامل ازاي
فبالتالي علاقتك مع المدرسين مع الدكاتره
تكون كويسه جدا
بيكتبوا انت مين في الفصل عملت ايه كنت
قاعد في اخر صف ما بتعملش حاجه خالص ولا
كنت قاعد في ناس تضحك هنا صح هم او في ناس
كانوا
بيطوعوا ناس كانوا بيساعدوا ناس كانوا
فايقين في قلب المحاضرات او في قلب
الكلاسيس بتاعتهم فبيكتب عنك زي كلام يشكر
فيك يقول والله ده احمد كان معايا
بيطلب منك اثنين واحد اكاديمي واحد بيكون
مللي يا شغل يتطوع
فتطوعت برضو علشان تلاقي حد يديك مش اي
حاجه وخلاص ساعتها هتعرف تسافر
قبل
رابع حاجه هي
دي ببساطه خالص صفحه او صفحتين بالانجليزي
بتكتب
بتجاوب مع الخمس اسئله مهمين قوي قوي قوي
بصوا يا جماعه دي كبسول المنح معظم المنح
ما بتطلعش من اوراق دي او من المتطلبات دي
او من الاسئله دي بتجيب خمس حاجات في واحد
هي انت مين ومين هنا مش انا عبد الله عندي
مش عارف كم سنه مش عارف اسكن فين لا انت
مين في الحياه دراستك بتحب ايه حتى هوايتك
مش مشكله تاني حاجه عملت ايه وايه يعني
عملت ايه عملت ايه يستحق ليه تقول عنه
وهنا بيقول لك ثاني اتطوع اتدرب اشتغل في
اي حاجه تدريب صيفي في اي حته لازم يكون
عندك حاجات تقولها يا فرحتي لما اكون حد
كويس ومحترم والتاني برضو كويس محترم بس
ده تطوع وفاه غيره فبالتالي هو بيختار لي
المنحه عشان كده بتلاقي في ناس بتقول ازاي
اخذ منحه لما جابش احسن واحد في الفصل
احسن واحد في المدرسه لو كان الشخص الواحد
مش عارف فين لا كان بيطوع كان حاجه كويسه
مفيده انت مين عملت ايه تلات حاجه مهمه
قوي عاوز تعمل ايه وما فيش حاجه اسمها انا
عاوز ادرس بره عشان بره التعليم حلو
ومحترم ونضيف وجميل وفي خضره وفي فسح وفي
كل حاجه حلوه لا
لازم اكون متخصص اكون عارف انا عاوز ادرس
ايه بالظبط ولازم اكون عامل ويا بخت يا
بخت الشخص اللي كان
شغال في الحاجه اللي نفسه يدرسها وهو هنا
فيقول لهم انا اشتغلت في واحد اتنين تلاته
او اتطوعت او قرات او رحت او حضرت او
اتعلمت واخدت فيها كورسات او حضرت وعاوز
اكمل عندكم في المجال اللي انا بحبه ده ده
ادعى تختار مش بس مجرد انا عشان جامعه رقم
مش عارف رقم واحد في العالم غلط لازم يكون
عندك سبب وبدات هنا
انت مين عملت ايه تدرس ايه
رابع حاجه تدرسه ليه وهنا يحضرني يعني هي
الرابعه والخمسه مع بعض مثال واحد يقول لك
انا هروح اتعلم عشان اتعلم وعملت كتير
ورحت وعملت هروح فايف ده كويس اهو ما فيش
اي حاجه لكن التاني نفس الاولاني ولكن هو
هنا قال انا هرجع اعمل واحد اتنين تلاته
عن طريق واحد اتنين تلاته بمعنى انا هروح
اتعلم انا من 13 سنه كتبت لهم جامعه
الازهر على فكره قلت لهم
المجتمع مهم جدا دي حاجه مهمه هو عاوز حد
مفيد في مجتمع مش عاوز حد يتاخد كده يقعد
في اللاب ولا في المكتبه وما يعملش حاجه
لان هو يذاكر خلاص لا انا عاوز حد يحتك
بالثقافه الثانيه وحاجه تطوع اتدرب اشتغل
اتمرمط وانت هنا عشان تعرف تتعلم بره
ابلكيشن ترانديشن
ستستفر كوريا اليابان المانيا تركيا اي
حته محتاج انجليزي انجليزي
عارفينهم طبعا صح
اشهر اثنين معروفين في حاجات كتير جدا
غيرهم الانجلش
امتحان تحديد مستوى
بس عالمي
هنا مش بس بياسس الانجلش بتاعك ويديك ورقه
كده وخلاص وحلها وخلص الموضوع لا ده كل
سكيل على حده وكل حاجه لها وقت معين
تعملهم فبالتالي تكون انت عارف مش بس
انجليزي هي شايفين الناس فاكره
دودج انجلش
بطريقه معينه مش بس اكسنت لذيذ لا في
كلمات معينه
علشان اعرف اقول للشخص انا اقدر اكتب بحث
علمي او اتعلم من حد دراسيا كويسه بالتالي
اعرف اقرا وابحث واروح واجي
في البرنامج بتاعك يكون واضح مش لازم يكون
معك جميله والكلام ده كلها
هتكون فاهم كذا اكسنت وكذا قولتر وكذا
حاجات فيها نيجيش الحاجات فيها نفي وحاجات
فيها اثبات مش بس مجرد
اختار ما تحته خط في مش بس تكتب موضوع
تعبيري وخلاص لا بيشوف بتاع الكلام بتاعتك
عامل ازاي والجمله عامله ازاي وانتقاء
الكلمات هل هو حاجه او فيها نوع من
يعني
الثقه والاحترافيه ولا هو حاجه
بنلاقي ناس جميله جدا وممتازه وقعه في
الانجليزي
عشان هو مش عارفين يجوا درجات حلوه في
الانجليزي فمن دلوقتي ابدا طور بنفسك خد
او خد الانجلش او خد تقفل
خذ الامتحان وطور نفسك
واحد صاحبي
اسبانيا دلوقتي
لف دول كتير ما شاء الله لف لف اوروبا
كلها على رجله كنا من كتر ما احنا بنشوف
ان هو بائس واستحاله يسافر كنا مش عاوزينه
اي خبر حلو عن اي منحه اخذناها او اي فرصه
او اي حتى منحه فاتحه جديده من كتر ما هو
قدم قدم 83 مره واترفض
في الاخر اتقبل مع اقامه ولسه متجوز الشهر
اللي فات كمان اهو الحمد لله اوروبا اللي
بتكلم فيه هتسقفه على ايه
هتسقفي على ايه ما تقوليش الكلام ده
هتتجوزي من هناك برضه ولا ايه
حاول كتير مش من مره ولا تانيه ولا في ناس
والله بشوفها خلاص هم خطوه وياخدوا المنحه
يفيصوا ما بتجيش من اول مره ولا تاني مره
ولا عشري مره ولا 15 مره في ناس اول مره
اول مره اقدم في حياتي الحمد لله سنه
كامله واكاديميه واروح الحاجات دي كلها بس
في ناس تيجي مره السبعه او مره الثامنه ما
تاخد خبره في الموضوع هنا في ابلكيشن
بتقدم كتير تاني حاجه
الموضوع مش موضوع خطك حلو في في الابلكيشن
ولا مجرد انت اديت لحد فلوس ولا تشات
خليته يكتب لك الابلكيشن دلوقتي لا هو
الانترفي والشخصيه اللي قدامي عامله ازاي
هو جميله وريحتها حلوه وزي الفل ومسرح
شعره بس عملي في حياته يستحق ان هو يتقال
فتطوع وتطور وتدرب واشتغل اي حاجه من
دلوقتي تعرف تقول الكلام ده في الانترفيو
اقدر اقول لكم بعد كده اللايف شكرا جدا
اللايف يور ايفر
في حد كده عايش حياته
يقال ليه ادرس هنا اشتغل هنا تدرب هنا
اتجوز هنا اعمل هنا عيش حياتك
في اي حته
وفي ناس تانيه لا عايز امام حياه الناس
كبرت ما شاء الله الشباب الصغيرين زيكم
اللي بنشوفهم دلوقتي حاليا بيقرر انا هدرس
ايه ولا اشتغل في ايه ولا اعمل ايه في
حياتي احنا عاوزين تكون في الطياره بتاعه
حياتك الرحله اللي انت رايحه دي انت اللي
ماسك
وماشي وطاير وتحدد ايه هي اتسرقت قد انت
النهارده الجمعه افتكروا حاجه مهمه جدا
جدا جدا ان لا نضيع اجر من احسن عملا انا
سوره الكهف علشان اي حد قدم واترفض صدقني
هيقعد لك في ايه بقى في شغلانه بعد كده
[تصفيق]